I asked artificial intelligence to write
me a recipe that would impress my hard
to please Korean mom and it came up with
a Korean beef patty that I'd had before
at restaurants but I never had a spicy
version or a version with cilantro in
fact I don't think I've ever had any
Korean food with cilantro in it so I was
definitely a little nervous to see what
my mom thought the only ingredient I
didn't have was gochujang but luckily my
mom had just brought some back from
Korea that her aunt had actually made my
mom may seem sweet but she is a harsh
critic especially when it comes to food
but AI did successfully write me a
recipe that went viral last week so I
finally cooked the patties and served
them with kimchi and rice and
wow did you make it I made it yeah oh
it's good
let me try it it's too salty
no